la promesse du président de la
république c'était de bâtir un monde
politique nouveau cette promesse elle
est morte la moralisation c'est le mot
d'ordre du tout premier gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron en 2017 on entre alors
dans le nouveau monde
en mai 2010 est la moralisation de la
vie politique est si importante pour le
nouveau président de la république qu'il
met un peu plus de temps que prévu à
former son gouvernement emmanuel macron
veut faire de la moralisation de la vie
publique son premier chantier le report
de 24 heures de l'annoncé de la
composition du gouvernement en est
peut-être un premier signe
officiellement il s'agit de vérifier que
les futurs ministres répondent aux
exigences de la haute autorité
ces 24 heures sont bien employé c'est
aussi cela la moralisation de la vie
publique ça commence par désagréables
comme celui là le 17 mai ça y est on
connaît la composition du premier
gouvernement dirigé par edouard philippe
on peut retenir l'arrivée de nicolas
hulot au ministère de la transition
écologique de bruno le maire au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
de jean yves le drian aux affaires
étrangères et puis de françois bayrou le
patron du modem place vendôme au
ministère de la justice il doit leur
portée la loi de moralisation de la vie
publique
premier grand texte du quinquennat tout
le monde sait ici que c'est une loi qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur
qu'il y a des années que je me bats avec
l'idée que cette loi ne devront l'écrire
et que tout est
naturellement dans cette affaire d'une
importance capitale pour que les
citoyens retrouvent un minimum de
considération et de confiance mais
quelques semaines plus tard une affaire
révélée par le canard enchaîné vise un
membre du gouvernement à richard ferrand
alors ministre de la cohésion des
territoires il lui est reproché en 2011
alors qu'il était directeur des mutuel
de bretagne d'avoir loué des locaux
commerciaux à une société immobilière
appartenant à sa femme alors forcément
l'opposition emmanuel macron crie au
scandale en pleine campagne des
élections législatives
la promesse du président de la
république c'était de bâtir un monde
politique nouveau est dans l'adn dans
marche il y avait la probité
l'intégrité l'exemplarité
cette promesse elle est morte quand la
première décision que vous prenez c'est
une loi de moralisation de la vie
politique dans moralisation et la morale
on peut pas venir nous disent expliqué
aujourd'hui que là les agissements de
monsieur ferrand sont acceptables dans
cette affaire le procureur de la
république de brest décide d'ouvrir une
enquête préliminaire et au sein du
gouvernement on ne lâche pas richard
ferrand ou alors on botte en touche je
respecte la décision du parquet et je
protège son indépendance et donc c'est
cette enquête qu'il faut attendre je ne
préjuge pas du résultat de l'an qué
aussi longtemps qu'il n'y a pas de mise
en examen il n'y a aucune raison de
demander à monsieur ferrand de quitter
le gouvernement et pourtant trois
semaines plus tard même si richard
ferrand n'est pas mise en examen il doit
quitter le gouvernement dans un
remaniement intervenant après les
élections législatives et à ce moment là
autres départs importants du
gouvernement pour des raisons
judiciaires celui de françois bayrou et
de deux autres ministres du modem leur
parti est mise en cause dans une affaire
d'emplois fictifs au parlement européen
françois bayrou doit quitter son poste
avant même d'avoir pu défendre sa voix
de moralisation de la vie politique je
n'accepte pas de vivre sans liberté de
parole
je n'accepte pas d'être condamné au
silence lorsque l'honneur de ce que je
représente est en jeu de surcroît cette
situation expose est le président de la
république et le gouvernement
l'on devinait bien que le débat qui se
prépare au parlement allait par ces
polémiques être détourné de son sens et
il se trouve
que j'accorde plus de prix au but à
atteindre à l'oeuvre que nous avons à
construire qu'à mon rôle personnel au
titre aux privilèges et au gallon cinq
ans plus tard le parti de françois
bayrou est toujours dans l'attenté de la
décision judiciaire dans cette affaire
d'emplois fictifs et pour la faire
ferrand la justice a estimé qu'elle
était presque prête
[Musique]